i remember
feeling
oh my god you know
how did this happen
because
a care home is a place where you expect
your loved ones to be safe
jean anderson lost her father cleo in
april 2020
he died in a care home where he caught
covet 19. the culpability as far as i'm
concerned is fairly and squarely with
the prime minister
and and his health secretary at the time
was ma hancock
it's so
disappointing um and i feel really
saddened
and i feel
angry as well
because
you know when i think that my father
could still be here today
the high court says the government acted
unlawfully when it allowed asymptomatic
or untested hospital patients to be
discharged into care homes
but both boris johnson and the former
health secretary matt hancock claimed
they were not advised about the danger
of asymptomatic transmission at the time
not true says the former shadow health
secretary i was raising the issue around
care homes right at the start of the
pandemic because everybody knows when an
infectious disease hits
that you're vulnerable in care homes are
at risk we were raising the issue of
asymptomatic transmission as experts
were
the 75-page high court judgment lists 20
occasions where the government's own
advisors and scientists raised concerns
about asymptomatic transmission
minutes from a sage meeting on the 4th
of february note asymptomatic
transmission cannot be ruled out
and transmission from mildly symptomatic
individuals is likely
a month later at a nerve tag meeting on
the 6th of march professor neil ferguson
from imperial said
the w.h.o report highlighted that
infectiousness seems to be just before
and just after symptom onset
and just a few days later
the health minister lord bethel told the
lords that large numbers of people are
infectious or infected but are
completely asymptomatic and never go
near a test kit
by the end of march 2020 there are at
least nine research articles documenting
spread before symptoms so that's very
people who never get symptoms and people
who spread before they become
symptomatic it being on tv it was in
several
of the sage minutes that matt hancock
could have seen and should have seen
jean deserves answers and she needs
accountability
now she is one step closer to learning
the truth
about her father's death
ashish joshi sky news